there's this magazine posted a photo of
you with your co-star in the movie Luke
Wilson you two conversation deep
conversation and what's nice is he plays
your your love interest in the movie and
you got to cast him so I'm just curious
what's that situation like because you
have the power to look through
catalogues of all these great leading
men pick Luke Wilson to make out with in
the parkin you're asking me well yeah I
am I'd make out with Owen first yeah I
don't know you know gorgeous and
wonderfully talented yeah you know and
we kissed and kissed and kiss and that's
maybe one of the good things about being
in charge I think we should do one or
two more I'm so sorry I know it's late
and we're tired it's probably but you
know it's five or six more stop crying
and kiss me again but it is you know I
think is neat about that is it's the old
Hollywood dynamic turned on its head you
know for 18 years and years there were
men in charge that we're saying okay
let's see that lady and it's so it's
neat that you're in charge and you're
saying that guy over here I mean he
didn't have to kiss me to get the part
but once he had the part it was part of
the job description right you did
lengthen those scenes hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please